good morning everybody good morning
to members here in offices good morning
to those who might be watching this
on the district council torres district
council's youtube
uh welcome to the plans committee
meeting in the first fifth of august
item one of the agendas of politics
thank you chair qualities from
councillor locke councilman
councillor belton however councillor
newton is subbing for councillor
belton thank you
now before we start with no public
speakers
registered today but i'll just ask all
the committee
to introduce themselves to the benefit
of anybody
watching on youtube um and then the
office is your presence as well
so i'll start by introducing myself i'm
chris leather
chair the committee and i'm a northern
web member
i am ruth craigie and i represent with
east
i'm margaret my vice chair and
representing great valentine
pete watson i represent rodney richard
wiseman i represent shamir and langtry
good morning my name is peter christie i
remember benefit
good morning simon newton and i
represent winter
members of the public my name is sean
harrington and i'm the planning manager
good morning my name is damian i'm the
legal services manager
good morning my name is graduate playing
officer
nelson
good morning i'm kirsty democratic
services officer
and we've got tom knows the technical
whiz kid who keeps everything running
everything all right and if it does go
wrong he knows it's always his fault
right item two on the agenda
declarations of interest members i think
know this off by heart now but i'll read
it for the benefit of everybody
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is being
considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils
who have considered a planning
application by virtue of their
membership
of that council hold a personal interest
and now deemed to have considered it the
application
separately and the express views of that
council
do not find the members concerned who
consider the application
refresh item three on the agenda is to
agree
the agenda between parts one and two
there is no part two to the agenda
there are two items on the agenda this
morning
two applications item four is urgent
matters and i think
my planning manager is something that
uh yes thank you chair uh just to make
members aware they're not already aware
that the nppf was revised at the end of
july
so there's a new version of the mvpf out
if members haven't
seen that i will happily circulate the
revised version
at the meeting today um the revised
version essentially um the paragraph
numbers will change
from revised version but it's more in
relation
to a greater emphasis on beauty and
there's talk of design codes
treeline streaks etc your officers are
currently reviewing the revised mppf and
we will be supplying a further update on
that and the implications to it
um the implications likely to be in
relation to level plan review
and requirements and codes so we will
send a further update
uh two members from the officers that
have reviewed it
thank you sean item five on the agenda's
public participation well as i mentioned
with no public speakers contributing to
the meeting this morning
item six is planning applications
the information recommendations and
advice contained
in the reports are correct as of the
date of preparation which is more than
10 days
in advance of the committee meeting due
to these time constraints
any changes or necessary updates to the
reports
will be provided in writing or orally at
the committee meeting
and our first application this morning
is application
6a at onelink0496
2021 full application and
that's on your page pages four to eleven
of your agenda
and peter stackley will present this one
thank you thank you very much
and good morning members and members of
the public
this application is for retrospective
application for the conversion
existing outbuilding to provide
answering annex accommodation
at 35-37 nelson road it's been heard
in front of plans committed today
because um the applicant is a member
and is a relative of a officer at torres
council
next slide please just to provide some
verbal updates
and in relation to what sean says um the
revised national planning process
framework
and paragraph 2.5 my report
um should read paragraph 126 of the
national
mppf and paragraph 4.1
my report should read the paragraphs
one-on-one of the mbps and one
two again
next slide please so here's the
location plan and with the application
site in the middle
and as you can see the main dwellings to
the south of the application side
with a series of outbuildings to the
rear
next slide please here's an aerial image
in context just to show the wider
surrounding areas of westward
and you can see the green on the top
left of that image there
and the application site is outlined in
red
these and here's just a closer image of
the application
site and outlined in red but
again you can see the main dwelling and
the business
and the south and the application site
the outbuilding to the north
alongside the immunity space and
next slide please so here's a view um
of the main access to the rear of the
property
on the left you can see the um
applications like men
dwelling above it with the business use
on ground floor
and on the right of that you can see the
neighboring property this is the main
access to the rear
of the application site
next slide please this is the highway
access
and view towards the east uh it is a
one-way street along here
and vehicles come towards you here
from the west next slide please
and here's highway access and looking
towards the east
uh again the vehicles it is a one-way
street
so the vehicle is going away from here
uh there is pedestrians like walk
um as you can see there next slide
please
here's the uh front elevation of the
uh answering accommodation in question
uh which is
subject to the application um
there are no changes um from the
previous use which was installed
um for the main dwelling and
it was already planned so there's no
changes in that respect
next slide please again just
in relation to the um the answer
accommodation relation to the main
dwelling
um which is the flat above the um
business use which you can see there
next slide piece and again just uh
kind of the front elevation context to
the other and remaining
of the outbuilding which is the carriage
and a workshop
used answering to the main dwelling as
well
next slope is there is a small private
immunity space
and again they're shared by the answer
accommodation and the
um main dwelling
next locations and again this is a view
from
the uh um on the front elevation of the
answer in combination here
looking east so you see the neighboring
property there
and then you've got the methodist church
on the left and there is
the high boundary fence there as you can
see
next slide please again this is the rear
elevation
uh there's no changes again there's no
um
outlook into the neighborhood property
um to the west
and that's the renovation dancer
accommodation
next slide please and again this is a
new
um kind of the rear elevation um
in context so i'm still in the car park
um
looking back onto the site there you see
the answer recombination and then the
main
property um in gray there
next slope is so on the left here we
have the existing floor plan
which was a store and with toilet
facilities
and bedroom living room
uh toilet the the answer accommodation
will be reliant on the main dwelling
for kitchen facilities so it's just
something three accommodation
next slide please and again so this is
the assisting and proposed elevations
uh there was no changes um the existing
post and it is as was
next main material considerations in
this case are principal development
impact from character appearance impact
on immunity
access parking and highway safety
ecology and
other matters i hope people read my
report why i recommend you for approval
of this application if you have any
questions
thank you peter anybody like to
start the discussion councilor watson
yeah thank you chair um
whilst i'm i am not a fan of
retrospective
i think people should be charged at
least travel the amount of money
to do with retrospective but i i've gone
through this
you know again last night and i don't
see them
for me i don't see any problems with it
um so
i'll i'll propose it all right
thank you councillor watson council
brown i see that northern parish
transform
recommending the application i lose a
football reaction the environment
protection officer
team have got no objections either so i
think i would like to second
maybe yourself or sean cannot answer
this ancillary
and so it annex accommodation that it's
not
an annex that's connected to the
property which is the tea room with a
flat oven
is it ancillary to the flatter bubble
yeah so
uh the application is owned as a whole
and it is connected to the rear
elevation of the main property
um and yeah it is absolutely flat
um but they do own the cafe as well so
um
and there's no kitchen facilities
there's no kitchen service in the any
accommodation
and they won't be reliant on the
dwelling
okay thank you right when it's been
moved and sounded for approval we'll
take the vote and all those in favor
[Music]
[Music]
our next application is on pages 12
to 19.
this is all application 1.80683
2021 full application for the secrets
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it just mentioned if we parish town
council
the application channel page 14.
oh sorry yes sorry i turned up two pages
that's your counselor christie's
declared his duel party doctors being
members thank you tristan
great so yes my name is tristan notten
i'm a graduate planning officer and
uh say good morning to the members this
committee
is watching at home and so this
application is before you
because it is on toys district council
land
um and it's for an access
so
and so here are the location plan in the
block plan
and as you can see the slightest access
from park plane
as in biddeford and to the north is the
king
playing fields into the south is wide
out victoria park
block fan shows in more detail the
surrounding buildings that are there
and it's just an aerial location planned
to show you the vegetation cover that
exists and as you can see to the south
west of the building there's quite a
dense vegetation cover that's where you
there's a small footpath but views are
quite difficult to see this side of the
building next slide please
and this is just a map to show you that
it is in the flood zone and the physical
drainage area
next slide please and a flood risk
statement was provided
which states that there's no change to
the existing flood situation as
there's already a concrete area there
[Music]
so the officer has recommended that this
is flood compatible because it is of you
know
of a concrete nature next slide please
and here's just a view of the entrance
so
that shows how pedestrians access the
site and
entrance is about 1.5 uh
105 centimeters wide sorry um
next slide please
and that's the development site for you
here
um it's looking south east so the ramp
would come from
fire exit door which you can just see
just on the left there of the building
and run down towards the other entrance
which already has an access ramp towards
it
next slide please
and it's just a proposal site again i
just took another photo
where there's a tape measure showing
roughly
where the access front would go
and in this case i'm just showing you
here that there's an existing
slope so this angle just shows you a bit
better that
the existing slope leads up to the door
further down the stream access towards
this
building let's select this
and this is just looking the other way
towards the exit and
so you can see the distance there the
gate that we saw in the first photo
and it's just north west and the next
photo
shows the slope and a bit more detail
against that's the existing slope and
new axis is proposed towards the
other door which is quite sealed up
and so these are the existing plants
but that shows a bit of the slope then
the proposed plans also show
where the new access front will go so
um here you can see that there's going
to be a ramp of about 0.5 meters in
height
with a railing which is 1.1 meters in
height
slope is about 1 in 20.
and it's about 1.1 meters wide
leaving a space where the existing
gap is of 1.2 meters so you'll have
access along the side towards the main
ramp and then this second
access will provide another access to
the rear door
and it's 1.1 inches wide
so these are the main planning
considerations but it's basically set up
in my report
so the principle of development is there
because it's
minor scale signing character
i have found major conflicts with the
plan and
um impacts on local immunity it's quite
hard to see
comes from the exterior of the site
and um parking is not affected by this
application
but the access uh has changed a little
bit towards the door but the main access
is still
there which goes towards the existing
round which goes towards the existing
talk
and as i said since the funding
situation has been considered a
risk statement was provided thank you
thank you tristan councillor christie
yeah well this is my award um and i
think we're all aware
somebody here today this is
[Music]
normally foreign proposal would accept
it but could i just have one thing i've
had
um quite a few uh comments now
uh this is obviously to help disable
people again
but if you go back to the map go back to
the map of the site
um you can see where there's an exit
onto park lane
and it's a very dear i think you see
it's a very acute angle there
and apparently um lots of children when
they come out here they don't look
left it is one-way pathway
a sign there just to warn drivers that
it is
you know they couldn't access it because
you're gonna have disabled people coming
out here now as well
yeah jeff i'll second it
thank you councillor watson
that doesn't actually form part of the
application site to this
does it no chair something that we could
do within this application
outside the application
it's quite heavily used and right
it's been moved by councillor christie
for approval
certainly by councillor watson we'll go
through the vote because all those in
favor please show
and that's unanimous thank you thank you
tristan
but the next item on the agenda
is item seven appeal decisions suddenly
there are no peer decisions
eight on the agenda is cost on appeals
and no
costs on the piece nine
i think uh gender item nine is delegated
decisions
agmv applications on page 20.
there's one there which was permitted
item 10 is the list of planning
decisions on pages
21-25
applications from the 13th of july to
the 22nd of july
pages 21
22 23
[Music]
24 closer crystal the council what's the
third earlier he doesn't like
retrospective yeah i'm intrigued there
are
three sort of existing normal use
applications on this
one list um because i've become involved
in one fairly contentious one
uh is there any reason why this is
happening
clearly people get upset because
if you like people have done it then
years later i saw it's legal now
and porridge have to give it basically
but it's really reason for
so many of these jaguars
yes um i don't believe there's been an
increase
in number of applications um it's
something i can certainly do
the research on that members know that
has been increased
um it is part of the planning system
that they can apply for certificates
and we do see social certificates
i haven't particularly noticed any
increase in members of those typicals
i can certainly do those stats for you
and come back to you
no it's all right i'm just intrigued
there are three on this fairly short
list
that's quite rare i think that we have
three on such a tourist um
can i ask a general question on seeing
this council of christians raise this
again
certificate of lawfulness is this
because
for some reason somebody's discovered a
site
that's that's got a use that wasn't ever
given planning permission so
either a ward member or a member of the
public is or even the
applicant themselves have applied for it
and then as we had that last week and
then councillor christie brought it up
again
it's just a case of evidence from
anybody who
may know anything about this and a
balanced judgment
yeah so um
as there are two um one for proposed use
and one for existing use
and they're both typically lawful
offenses the proposed use
is when somebody's asking could be
lawful so some could be committed
developments for example
and the existing use is the one which i
think council christie is
more concerned about when it uses to go
ongoing without
planning permission and that's in this
excuse um
one of the triggers for applications to
the localness tends to be enforceable
action
so if the enforcement officer goes and
investigates the site and it hasn't got
planning permission
then there's an option for that person
if they have been using it fully
represented in times of time
which is four years for development 10
years for change of use
changes for single dwelling which is
four years and then that may also
trigger stimulated lawfulness
certificate lawfulness certification is
also
triggered by conveyancing um in quite a
lot of top
instances where somebody's trying to
sell a property a piece of land
and they realize we'll purchase the
inventor realizes that they haven't got
their specific planning commission
um or their american use that period
time and that would also trigger us
so there's various different reasons why
would be
submitted to council
okay all right thank you for that
sean page 25
is the one that's been refused
there's no public here there's no part
two
so i just mentioned to you i declare the
meeting down close thank you
thank you for